we have spoken a lot about the links
between biodiversity loss
and covet now we must move to action
it is why we will protect at least 30
percent
of land and sea here in europe
we are ready to broker the same ambition
at global level
at the next u.n biodiversity summit in
kunming a year
ago at davos we talked also intensively
about digitalization
the business model of online platforms
has an impact and not only on free
and fair competition but also on our
democracies
our security and on the quality of our
information
and that is why we need to contain
this immense power of the big
digital companies we want it clearly
laid down
that internet companies take
responsibility
for the manner in which they disseminate
promote
and remove content the challenges to our
democracy
the pandemic climate change
in his inauguration speech president joe
biden
so aptly spoke of a cascade of crisis
and indeed we face an outstanding set of
challenges
but we can meet them if we work together
and that's what we all have to learn
again after
four long years that it is
not a sign of weakness to reach out and
help each other
but a signal of strength the point is
that it is only by working together
across borders and across
sectors that we can tackle our global
challenges